5 50 40 wednesday morning how about
standing up for the men and women who
wear orange standing in the middle of
traffic you know there are
too many days weeks and months of
different types of recognition to keep
track of but
we are right in the middle of one
national work zone awareness week
started back in 2000 to bring attention
to safety issues in work zones
here's part of a powerful video drivers
slamming into the rear
slowing and stopping vehicles is the
number one cause of work zone crashes
and the most common cause of
construction worker deaths and injuries
is from unexpected contact with heavy
equipment
vehicles and objects in the work zone so
the national transportation the
department of transportation that is in
the federal highway administration a
bunch of other partners
they're all hoping that we can pay good
attention whenever we're in or around
the work zones that yeah
sometimes do drive us crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com